thank you
and uh welcome everybody to this latest
meeting of the trafford covid
19 public engagement board uh
i'd like to start by by just reflecting
saying that today
we've come to terms with the grim news
that 100
162 people in this country have now
perished as a result of kobe 19 with
that those figures
continuing to rise last week we learned
that one of their number
was police constable abbas uddin who
served the trafford community
i would therefore like to start the
meeting by taking a minute of silence
to remember not just constantly but all
the victims of this terrible pandemic
thank
you
thank you uh let's proceed with our
business then uh attendances
uh i have apologies for absence this
morning from joanne gibson
rebecca demayne i believe martin
pritchard is here for her jill mcgregor
caroline hemingway welcomed nick young
in her place dorothy evans and i welcome
simone
is it on yemen uh in her place as well
um thank you um
are there any other apologies at all
thank you our declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
in any of the business
that we are dealing with this morning
from members but are present
thank you uh the minutes of the last
meeting
uh i assume we've all had time to read
them can we take those as an accurate
record of the meeting please
and approve them again
thank you very much so moving on then to
item four
updates on the current code with 90
situation in traffic and i passes
to eleanor thank you elena thank you
very much
um councillor freeman and um and thank
you for starting the meeting
in that way because it is a very very
sad day i think for this country
um and i wanted to add my tributes to
the 406
people in trafford who have died and to
extend my
my sympathy and i'm sure the sympathy of
all of us to their friends and to their
families and it's just
too many people and we we have to do
better
we have to do better so we
we need to be thinking how we in traffic
can do everything we possibly can to
stop this number of deaths increasing
because
it's it's a disgrace it's a disgrace
and it's a tragedy um i mean i'm pleased
to note that our rates are coming down
they're coming down slowly the new
variant of the disease
is very much more infectious and that
means that the things that we were doing
previously that were probably good
enough
are just not working for all of our
population anymore
so businesses that had been operating
okay had not had cases they're suddenly
seeing a lot of cases
um we're just and and again um
the numbers in in households again that
big spread within households now
where previously perhaps not everybody
in the household would have been ill
we're seeing a lot more spread within
those households
so it really is everybody needing to
think about how they take additional
care
um i mean in the last weekend i say our
numbers are coming down but in the last
week to the 23rd of january we had 709
people in trafford who tested positive
for covid
i mean that's a lot of people a lot of
individuals
and that's just the people who went for
the test and got that positive test
result
there will be more um
so how can we help people to follow the
guidance people are tired but most
people
are really compliant with guidance i
just i you know they're
not everyone of course but what i see is
most people doing their very very best
to to live by the guidance and actually
we're all living very very differently
so when people say people aren't taking
this lock down as seriously as the first
one i think actually you know what we
are taking it seriously because when you
see the way people are wearing the face
marks
when you see the way people are behaving
i see a lot of people being really
really responsible
but what i think we could do more of and
i think we need to do more of
is making sure that we make it as easy
as possible for people to do those
the right things and to limit their
social contacts
and i would particularly implore
businesses to think about how they're
operating at this time
if you have people in the office who
could be working from home
make them work from home do not
encourage people to come into the office
people should be working from home if
they possibly can if they can't work
from home and
and lots of businesses that's not
possible make sure that
all your covered security arrangements
are absolutely rigorously applied
absolutely support your staff and
support your staff to be honest with you
if somebody is feeling ill make sure
they go home make sure they get a test
make sure that they feel able to share
their contact details with people that
they don't feel there will be punishment
for them
if they share those contact details and
and support them
financially to make to make sure that
they are able to self-isolate
if they need to do so absolutely
critical at this time that we get these
numbers down
and we are seeing a number of outbreaks
in businesses where
where it really has spread far faster
than it should have done
and what i'm seeing sometimes is that
the business policies and procedures
look beautiful on paper
but are you absolutely sure that they
are being applied correctly
are you auditing against your policies
and procedures to make sure
that everything is in place and that all
the actions are being
uh being adhered to by the workforce and
how are you making it easy for the
workforce
to adhere to that so um
that's that's my plea to businesses
today
to absolutely help get these numbers
down
and the second thing i want to talk
about is the vaccination program and the
vaccination program is an amazing
program and we really do want to
pay tribute to tribute to all of our nhs
colleagues for the amazing the work that
they've been doing in setting up that
program
and getting it running so quickly and so
efficiently
but what i want to say to people is when
you're asked to go for your vaccination
it is a prioritized system and it's been
prioritized because the people in the
top groups
are the people who are most likely to
die or to end up in hospital for covert
covet is not a trivial illness and this
vaccine is safe
and it's effective and it will help you
it could save your life
and what we've seen throughout is
inequalities um
being sure you know the impact of
inequality that's been highlighted by
covid
is staggering and please please don't
contribute to those inequalities
by not taking that vaccine if you've
been asked to come for a vaccine
it's for a reason and it's to make you
safe my parents got
their vaccination there in their 80s
they got their vaccination on my
birthday this year
and it was the best birthday present i
could ever have so i just want to say to
people please please please
take up the vaccine but don't change
your behavior afterwards it takes a
little while to work
but it's worth having and look after
yourselves
that's what i would say
thank you elena are there any questions
at all from the
members to eleanor
if you if you want to you could raise
your hand to anybody i don't see any
oh yes councillor welton please
hi uh thanks chair um thank you very
much for that update eleanor
um i just wanted to raise a couple of um
a couple of
issues that i don't think well i don't
remember us
raising in this meeting before the first
ones regarding the
helpful helpfulness of vitamin d and
whether there's something that we can do
as a council to um
to either publicize that or even make
make vitamin d available to
members of the community that might
benefit from it obviously you know
particularly with people
spending more time indoors with the
lockdown um you know whilst people are
trying to get outside and exercising
they're probably not going to get as
much as they
would normally and obviously at this
time of year it's difficult to get it
naturally anyway
second thing is is that we get getting a
steady flow of
um complaints into our counselor inboxes
about
about open fires about log burners
and uh and the contribution to air
pollution and obviously in this this is
a respiratory
um pandemic respiratory
emergency and should we be asking people
to
cut down on the amount of open fires
they have to improve
particularly in urban settings um to
improve the
ability generally uh to uh assist in
this emergency times should we be asking
for
asking people to make that that small
sacrifice
thank you so i'm going to start with log
burners and i would say absolutely yes
i'm really sad to say it but then i
would love to have a log burner but they
are not safe
they they are pollutants and they give a
lot of pollution in the house
um so the latest studies do show that
even they'll seem even the highest
quality ones
are quite polluting and obviously in a
lot of cases that
people um haven't haven't necessarily
you know i think quite often people have
bought
log burners thinking they're doing
absolutely i know people have bought
them
thinking they're doing absolutely the
right thing but they are very very
polluting
um and an open fire is is even more
dangerous
um absolutely you you know we should not
be we should not be having
people people should not have log
burners um in their homes
it is not safe particularly for the very
old and the very young
on vitamin d i would say
yes vitamin d is available and we do
need it all of us
i used to think that my extraordinarily
pale complexion would mean that i was
quite um quite in a better position than
people with
but um the many but uh even so people as
pale as me
do need to take additional vitamin d
through the winter
if we're living you know living at these
northern latitudes uh there isn't enough
sunshine
so my understanding is that vitamin d is
available now and i think martin maybe i
don't know whether it's
um through i don't i doubt it through
prescription but i know it is being
promoted
i don't know martin if you can say
anything from primary care perspective
although i think the evidence i mean the
evidence for it isn't
it the evidence for vitamin d generally
is good
um how much it helps specifically with
covet i think the jury is still out
but it's it's a good thing to have your
vitamin d levels kept up
um definitely martin i don't know if you
can add from how people access it
thank you elena um i don't have the
answer to my fingertips
but uh i will i will get back to you on
that one
we can put a link onto the um covet
pages the website we can definitely
um i'll talk to colleagues about putting
some of the evidence reviews as i say
the evidence is a bit
mixed there are a few people who need to
take care
um if they have some other conditions
they do need to take a bit of care
if they take large doses of vitamin d so
we would urge
a little bit of caution before you take
a very large dose of vitamin d
just because in a few in a few
conditions it will be contraindicated
but again we can put some guidance out
um
both on our corona various pages and
martin i'm sure you put it on the
ccg website as well
uh thank you eleanor uh any further
questions at all
uh council welton do you want to come
back
yes thank you very much that was uh very
helpful can i ask
you obviously you made some very fairly
strong
um views known there about the um about
the log files and things like that
can i ask if that's a personal opinion
or is that is that reflected in council
policy
and is there going to be any action
maybe mike can help with that
um councillor freeman can help with that
maybe uh you know is there going to be
any kind of
messaging going out from the from the
point of view of the council on this
issue thank you
that's my personal opinion it's not
council policy i'm the director of
public health so i'm in a very
privileged position as a
council officer to um to be able to give
my independent voice and that is my
assessment it's certainly something that
i think as part of the clean air work
we would want to look at but the
contribution of log burners
to be fair i think the contribution of
log burners and the harm that log
burners do is more to the internal air
quality in the homes
and probably less to the external air
quality
although we could have a look at that uh
the biggest threat
to air quality in trafford remains
cars vans lorries so i would definitely
um
you know i'm very much and the council
has fully engaged in all of the work to
reduce the
air pollution levels from transport as
part of the clean air work across
greater manchester
um but i'm happy to discuss with
councillors um
uh the role of the log burner
thank you elena and i would say to your
counselor welton that of course it's
part of the
work we're doing around clean air that
log burners would be
looked at as part of that work and i'm
sure that the
council leader as the uh climate change
lead for greater manchester is on that
case as we speak thank you
uh any further questions
right can we move on then to the ten
point action plan or as it stands
mass testing in trafford i invite donna
to speak to us thank you donna
donna you're on mute
sorry chem i am my bandwidth says it's
very low so if i drop
out if one of my colleagues could pick
up from me um
so apologies from that and i'm also
speaking with a mask on so i'm sure
that's not helping
um just wanted to update you on the
asymptomatic testing site that we've set
up
for key workers um which is now up and
running in trafford town hall
we had 2528
key staff members attend over the last
two weeks which
is a really positive service
it was designed to particularly work
with those staff members who are
with our most vulnerable residents in
the community
um and um we've had responses forty
staff
homeless services staff and things like
that so that's a really positive
contribution
schools are progressing with their own
testing regime i'm not sure if helen's
managed to get on the call yet
but we know the primary school started
with their own lateral flow devices
um on monday and secondaries have now
been using it to test stuff
um since uh for the last couple of weeks
special schools are working towards that
as well um the other site that we've
just recently set up is
one at amy which is for our key
contractors
uh again we're doing that on a pilot
basis um and obviously
our care homes and our supported living
tenancies
are using natural flow tests to make
sure that they
are able to start work safely and uh
reduce the risk of transmission of that
virus
thank you thank you
uh don can i just say i do know that the
the testing site we've got at trafford
town hall has been
hugely welcomed by many many different
groups i know as a
chair of governors at a primary school
that the staff from
there are attending regularly and are
hugely grateful to the council
for opening up the testing to to primary
school teachers
i understand we also are now also
testing people from
uh traffic housing trust uh some from
tesco's is that correct ellen because of
the issues there
and other groups so i think it's been a
really really worthwhile
worthwhile project and i hope that i
understand
the army are only there for six weeks
but i understand we are now looking
at how we're going to resource it going
forward
uh which i think is is absolutely vital
so thank you
correct yes any questions at all for for
donna
i i do mike but i don't have a hands-up
feature okay then nathan go on
and it'd just be just interest really if
you've tested two and a half thousand
ish people at the asymptomatic test
what was the uh i don't know if it's
failure rate or positivity rate what was
the actual
rate be interesting to know how many
people that were asymptomatic
uh fail the test i suppose
positive result
yes it's about yes yeah
yeah early days counselor but um we're
looking at a range between 0.8
and 1.6 of uh tested were positive
so it's a very low numbers still quite
worrying because that's where we were
back in
sort of uh april may if you remember
rightly
we felt that was sort of acceptable but
and
it still led us down a thorough pattern
that
it's a concerning number it's a low
number i accept that but it's
still quite confusing it's not 25 people
i think it's
sorry i think it it shows that the
services are valuable one counsellor as
well
thank you for that thank you councillor
evans any further questions at all
thank you donna for that update can we
move on to mass vaccination in traffic i
invite martin
pritchard to address his martin
thank you chair so um
just a reminder that the size and scale
of this
vaccination program which is a ahead of
us
the ambition for the uk is that every
adult will be
offered a vaccination during 2021 which
is uh
is a huge undertaking and
in nhs trafford as a governing body we
are very clear
that we are adopting four key principles
to guide
this work the first is that we will
offer that vaccination
in line with need and what that
practically means is
working our way through the jcvi cohorts
in order in lockstep with the rest of
the nhs
across england and that includes uh
the approach to health and care staff
and
i want to thank council colleagues for
the work that they've done jointly with
the nhs
in terms of working through the the
detail of what is a
on its own a hugely complex program just
for
health and social care staff so thank
you for that
the second principle is that we
absolutely need to
maximize the the public health benefit
of this program
as eleanor has outlined and what that
means is
focusing that vaccination program by
giving as many first doses to people as
possible
and therefore reducing the impact on our
health and social
care system in the short term and you
will have all seen
that in terms of where we are as a
health and care system
this is the absolute big point in terms
of the number of people who
have been providing critical care across
the uk
and the number of people who are
currently being cared for in our
hospitals
so the enormous effort that everybody
has put in
to this point we are hopeful of starting
to see the impact of that
over the next few weeks and that's why
it's critically important that we
we approach in that way the third
principle about
is about supporting equity of access to
the vaccine
and in terms of how we practically
support that
it's by working with those vaccination
providers
to enact a program of mutual aid to make
sure that we
get the vaccines to in the right numbers
to the right places in order to do that
and then the fourth one is absolutely to
maximize our coverage by
not wasting a single drop of
any of the vaccines that we receive
and at times that can give people some
real operational
day-to-day issues because particularly
with a fisa vaccine
it has a very short shelf life and
sometimes people have to make we have to
trust our clinicians to make sensible
decisions
about how they maximize the use of those
vaccines so that's the approach we're
absolutely
taking and we are being consistent in
our approach and working with our
vaccinators to support that approach
as an nhs in in trafford
we have um between us
vaccinated over 33 and a half thousand
uh people who live in trafford at this
point
and that includes the work of our
primary care networks
for whom the majority of those people
have been vaccinated through that
but also our community pharmacists uh
particularly want to pay tribute to our
community pharmacist in timperley
but also to our hospital colleagues
because now we have
the trafford general hospital as a
vaccination site for health and social
care staff
and although these hospitals aren't in
albura
we also have very close to our borough
salford royal
manchester royal infirmary and wooden
shore who are sites of vaccinators for
health and care staff and we also have
the mass vaccination center
at the etihad tennis and football centre
so
the combined efforts of all of those
people working
in all those areas all the brilliant
volunteers have stepped forward and
helped us is as i say
over 33 and a half thousand people today
who
live and live in trafford have received
a vaccination
and that from a standing start in a few
weeks is an absolutely
brilliant start of something that is
going to be
a huge program of work throughout the
rest of this year
we have um vaccinated nearly everybody
who lives in a care home to the elderly
in trafford
there are a very small number of people
who are not well enough to receive their
vaccine
in the first instance and what we're
working is to make sure that we go back
and make sure that those people are off
the vaccination
and we're working with our partners to
make sure we're absolutely clear
and i'm sorry i'm going to use a
management phrase now absolutely clear
about what the standard operating
procedure is
for people who are admitted to a care
home or discharged from a hospital into
a care home
so we make sure that we're constantly
making sure that we are vaccinating the
most vulnerable in our society
we're also now and i think it was last
week but to be honest
um since we've all been working seven
days a week since before
new year i've actually lost track of the
weeks and i think it was last week
we now have a standing operating
procedure that allows us to vaccinate
the house bound
and one of the real focuses of the
moment is making sure that we are now
vaccinating our housebound again some of
our most vulnerable people
and we're really working really hard to
do that
so we're we're making really good
progress share we're all working
really hard and supporting each other
and
i don't want to put words in in the
mouth of the people on this committee
but a recognition of that i think would
be very welcome given how
tired people are now hard that they're
working in that
there are operational issues that
continue to be the operational issues
with something the size and scale of
what we're talking about there will be
operational issues
uh throughout the entire year around
this
um but please recognize the overall
effort that's gone into that and the
great start we've made in trafford
so that's by a way of update and of
course happy to answer
all of your questions chair thank you uh
thank you martin
and before i invite questions i think
it's very important we do place on
record our thanks
to all the nhs staff uh the council
staff
everybody that's involved in this mass
vaccination program and
the fines that we've had and kind of
including that
the volunteers that we had who have
attended um at our
site to marshall uh residents in and out
and without them we would really have
struggled as well
so i think that's it's important we do
mention the volunteers
uh councillor evans you've got your hand
up would you like to come in
tell you my opinion at all
councillor evans
can you all make sure you're on mute
counselor evans have you got a question
at all for
martin can you hear me
yes come on
no no no we can't hear you at all
sorry do you want to put your question
in the text and
i'll come back to you any other
questions at all please
uh counselor newgross it's actually more
of a thanks i mean
a thanks from timpali for identifying
what might have been a not spot and
mitigating that
martin very much appreciated by the
residents
and feedback from almost i mean all of
the residents i've talked to that have
been vaccinated
about the care the the standards
and the treatment they got was they were
blown away exceptional and raved about
it
in every single case from every single
site so i want you to pass that on
the appreciation of the locals that have
had these vaccines is very
very high so just thank you um
if there is a question it might just be
um
could you quickly go through the cohorts
um the over 80s the
uh so over 80s are complete i assume
or have all been offered uh care homes
all been offered apart from the most
uh ill um on the third cohort what what
percentage have we done and
i'm assuming this is one dose um at the
moment
on that cohort that's my question apart
from the praise
thank you uh and thank you for the
praise counselor uh
um it has been an exceptional effort and
i absolutely want to echo that the the
role of volunteers in the community of
this has been absolutely outstanding
um all the way through the response to
the pandemic and particularly with
response to this
in terms of the cohorts and i know ellen
in the very nicest way will correct me
if i get this wrong
um the first four four cohorts are
essentially
those people in who live in elderly care
homes and staff
those people aged over 80 those people
who work in
health and social care those people
aged above 75 those people aged above 70
and those people who are clinically
extremely vulnerable
they are the people in the first four
cohorts
and and eleanor will will have better
facts and figure than us
than i do but in terms of the people
most likely to become seriously ill
most likely to require hospital
treatment and unfortunately most likely
to die
most of those people are in those first
four cohorts
so that's where we are in terms of the
um in terms of the over 80s
one of the frustrations at the moment is
i don't have
the really accurate data at this point
because of reasons we've talked about
about we've got different
different clinical systems all feeding
one point i am confident in that figure
of
33.5 000 in terms of the total but at
the moment
i can't accurately break that down i
hope the next time i come and speak to
you i'll be able to give you a breakdown
of where we are in terms of the cohorts
but i can't accurately
do that at this point um i know
i don't know through um talking to
primary care networks through talking to
the staff
involved i'm pretty sure that the large
majority of the over 80s have been
provide
offered a vaccine at this point but i
can't give you accurate figures on that
there will always be some people who
haven't for some reason for other
and in the same way with care home
residents
we need to constantly go back and check
that we've picked up all the people from
the higher cohorts
as we continue to go through the lower
cohorts in this
so it's not the detail it's not the
level accuracy i'd like to give you in
detail in answer to your question
but as we go through this program we'll
get better and better in terms of that
quality of that data
thank you martin can i bring eve in
please to ask a question eve
hi uh thank you um just for those who
don't know me i'm
eve mannering he's the chief exec of
salford and trafford local medical
committee
and i represent uh general practice on a
day-to-day basis
and um and i just wanted to thank
everybody for the positive
comments that have been made on screen
and also
in the chat i just wanted to elaborate
as well very very briefly on what martin
mentioned around operational issues
because i
i feel there's um some work that we
could really
benefit from happening uh locally in
trafford and nationally
that the gpc the general practitioners
committee
is raising um in the national press is
a lot of the operational issues that
everyone's facing
aren't down to issues at locality level
it's down at the logistics and
operational level at national level
whereby practices and pcns are giving
a given very short notice less than 24
hours if
deliveries aren't going to be made um
and also
if they are and and the quantities often
um delivery sites have planned for
12 to 1700 vaccinations in a clinic and
then they receive 400 vaccines
so um i've i've been monitoring
some of the press locally and there's
clearly some obsessed amongst residents
in trafford
about the fact that um clinics have been
cancelled or priority lists have changed
last minute but i i think it's really
important for the public to understand
that some of this happening is well
outside control of the ccg
and the gps and all of the staff
so i'd like to pick that up with the
comms team separately
if that's possible thanks save i'm sure
that will be possible and
it's something that uh i'm a as an exec
member i've been aware of that
the the the um release of the the
vaccine is outside of the control of of
gps and the ccg and we really just get
what we're given um
and but let's just hope that you know
the numbers we want keep arriving on a
weekly basis because i think we are
doing
a very very good job in traffic anyway
thank you thank you
um i've got any further questions at all
mike could you pick mine up out the chat
yes out out of the chat
nathan has said he commenced the team
there's been some negative publicity
about the misuse of a reserve list
this is unfair and i'd like to suggest
at the end of the day we support our
conditions
to make those end-of-day decisions to
use vaccine without criticism
thank you nathan i think that's a and
that's a very reasonable point at the
end of the day
if there are no further questions for
marty then can we move on to
updating escalations from the community
engagement team and i invite nigel smith
to address us thank you nigel
morning thank you chair so just just a
few things to update
on from me so in terms of the work of
the community engagement team
we as i mentioned last time that this
group has this team has been
put together to focus on and coordinate
community engagement work related to to
cope with 19
and the intention was to have four local
neighborhood
leads up until now we've just had two
leads but i'm pleased to tell you that
we've now appointed to
the other two leads so one person is
starting tomorrow
and the other side of next week so as of
next week we'll have a full complement
of
uh neighborhood leads that'll really
help us and give us that additional
capacity that we need
and to have that real neighborhood focus
that was always the intention
and we also are now part way through
recruiting to some other supporting
roles so that's all looking really
really positive uh in terms of the
community champion scheme which again i
mentioned
last time and this is a scheme that's
operated by
the ministry of housing communities and
local government we put in a bid in
december for some funding
and we've had the confirmation last week
that that bid has been successful from
trafford so that again is really good
news
uh there has been a bit of national
coverage on that uh
sunday monday this week uh so you may
have picked up on that as well
nationally
so um that funding is to help us to kind
of fund some of that additional resource
that i've
talked about and help us to ramp up our
community engagement work
uh but in particular that uh funding
is there to help engage with our
communities that are
i've been most disproportionately
impacted uh on
covid so for example albane communities
or older people or those
people um living in poverty so that
that's where
a lot of that focus is going to be and
it's going to be around
us um recruiting a network of community
champions
uh across uh the borough that represent
those uh communities so we're gonna be
working also with our gm colleagues on
this
work because most of the gm authorities
have always had some funding
and to kind of share that resource where
we can and
we'll be able to progress the board with
activity
in future future meetings in terms of
volunteering i know
volunteering's been mentioned already
but the community engagement team have
been
supporting that with uh supporting the
ccg and
thrive colleagues with helping to
coordinate those volunteers
um and you know in terms of helping
patients coming forward of vaccinations
for example linking in with the
richest red cross the hub volunteers and
working with faith groups
at the larkil center in temple at the
live center in sale
to provide volunteers in terms of the
vaccine
we have been uh developing an action
plan with
comms colleagues at the council and the
ccg
to encourage to take up the vaccine and
reassure those who may be
hesitant about uh taking the vaccine so
from an engagement point of view the
priority for us
here is really going to be around
engaging again with those communities
who may be more hesitant or reluctant
to take the vaccine and an example of
one of the projects that we're doing is
working with
some young people at a local high school
in developing videos which they can
share with their peers so that's a
really good project
and be really interested to hear any
thoughts that elected members may
have on any insights you have in terms
of what barriers you
potentially see or are hearing or seeing
on the ground with people that may be uh
you know preventing people from coming
forward so be good to hear any
feedback for themselves on that and
finally just in terms of business
engagement
um ellen has already touched on this
right at the start
um so this is a focus for us
um we know our economic growth team
send our regular business bulletins and
advice to businesses and our
environmental health team are there
focused on the enforcement side of
things
one thing that we thought would be a
good idea which we're working
with our comms team and our economic
growth team on is looking at developing
a business web
webinar which will be aimed at giving
an update to businesses and key messages
from eleanor or other colleagues from
the public health team
around the importance of businesses
complying and meeting the covert secure
guidelines
and the steps to take should any
employees be positive or need to be um
to isolate and we'll also want to
to involve local businesses in that as
well if we can to talk about their
experience and lessons learned
so we're working towards hopefully
having the first webinar next week
and if that's successful to roll that
out with
uh future webinars perhaps tailored with
tailored messaging aimed at different
types and
sizes of business so those are the key
things i wanted to highlight
today chair uh thank you united before i
take questions
uh community champions uh i assume
they're gonna play a very very important
role in in messaging to these
communities
um my fear is is that as we vaccinate
more and more people
and our figures infection rates continue
to fall
there'll be a huge pressure to ease
restrictions
and the danger is of course if we use
restriction
whilst we'll be led by the government if
you ease restrictions too
soon or people become blase
we risk going backwards i don't if you
want to comment on that eleanor at all
absolutely i think we do need to
understand that the vaccination program
the vaccines that have been developed
are about
reducing the risk of death or
hospitalization
and hope we're hopeful that they will
also reduce
um transmission but the evidence for
that is
being collected now if you like as we as
we see that vaccine
program rolling out so at the moment we
would have to assume that it
i think it's safest to assume that the
vaccine may make you
may you may get it covered but be
asymptomatic or very mildly symptomatic
so actually if you change your behavior
you could be more dangerous to people to
other people
than you were previously so um because
you might you might
move from being somebody who would have
had it quite badly to being somebody who
has it very mildly
or is asymptomatic and that means that
you know if you start going out and
about
you you are really risking other
people's health so we would very much
advise people to continue to be
extremely cautious
especially while we've got the rates of
covert circulating that we do have um
it is something we we're not going to
come out of this very quickly
unfortunately thank you
i have a question from councillor welton
thanks chair um i just don't have a
quick look at the uh map of daily
confirmed cases
for um uh for the borough
uh i'm just noticing that that does seem
to be for the first time a real
north-south divide
um you know with their cases in you know
up in the up in the northern wards
some of the north awards are still well
over five you know well over 500
um and uh you know down in the south i
mean
you got hail at 95 and and some are in
the hundreds or
or low 200s um is this something that we
need to be
aware of do we have it can we do we have
a kind of reason for it and
how can we tackle it so the main reason
for it
is probably that um in poorer areas
more people are likely to be doing
face-to-face work
and less likely to be able to work from
home and that means that they are going
to be more likely to be exposed and with
the new more infectious variant which is
the dominant strain in trafford at the
moment
well over three quarters of our cases
are for that strain that means that that
spread
is faster and easier and therefore any
contacts that people are having
make it more likely that they will
either get it themselves and if they get
it that they will spread it
so what we're really seeing is that
inequalities if you're if you're living
in a household with a number of other
people um without a lot of space to
spread around you're more likely it's
much more difficult
for the other people living with you not
to catch it from you so we're we're
really seeing the impact of a lot of
inequality in this in
in um if you're if you're in a job where
you can work from home
um where you have space in your home
it's it's easier for you to protect
yourself
so i think that's that's the risk um i
would say that
all of our awards remain at over 50 per
hundred thousand which is the who
guidance
for the sort of cut-off point for being
concerned and the fact that we have this
widespread across the whole of the
borough
i would say we still are in a situation
which we've been
really since the summer where we have
cases seeded across the borough and it
is extremely easy for them to take off
if you you know if you lift your garden
that's what we've seen repeatedly
we've seen numbers come down
restrictions lift and numbers shoot up
again
because we we have not got on top of it
in any area within trafford
so i think ev all of us need to be
cautious
extremely cautious and seeing an area
with a rate of
100 per hundred thousand well it's much
better than the net the much better than
seeing um
the six and seven hundreds in some areas
that we were seeing a couple of weeks
ago
it's still it's still much much higher
than we would like
much higher and the risk is still very
very real at those rates
across the whole of the borough
thank you elena are there any other
questions at all
i don't see any um
can we therefore move on to the update
and escalation so on the community
enforcement group with
helen grant and i know helen you've
circulated a paper which is very useful
is there anything you'd like to add to
that paper thank you helen
um now just to reiterate that the
enforcement group meets
weekly to coordinate activity um
and also there's been an additional
meeting set up between
environmental health and grace
manchester police to be
more responsive as opposed to things
that are going on in a pandemic things
can move quite quickly
um and i think as eleanor touched on
before around a couple of the
larger businesses and previously haven't
had issues have now seen kind of
outbreaks
that's been able to kind of respond to
those things quite quickly
um i suppose i kind of echo as well what
eleanor said
around businesses and offices complying
with the code with guidance and if
they've got stuff that can work from
home to encourage them
to do so my team deal with kind of
issues around
residential premises a lot and i think
if we're trying to get the message
out there to get residents to comply
with the guidance but then they're going
to have to work in an office with 20
other people it
it seems nonsensical to them so it's
being consistent around that in all
environments to encourage people to
to comply um and i know that a business
bulletin
was issued last week and welcomed what
nigel just said about the
business webinar um we
have seen an increase so we had a kind
of reduction in
reports just after christmas when we
came back and it was a little bit
quieter and then
we've seen an increase in the last week
we do often see that when
there is a kind of government
announcement and i know when the home
secretary did her
kind of briefing there was a little bit
of an influx um around that
and i know grace manchester police if
they're seeing kind of like when
you know disregard of the regulations
we'll issue fixed penalty notices
we do pick up um the residential
premises
we do find that our kind of engagement
and warnings with people
is effective and we don't get many
repeats
some of the cases that we deal with are
from residents who
are you know well intentioned and
well-meaning but may have
you know misunderstood the situation
because somebody's got a family member
in a support bubble or whatever going
going around and so we have to kind of
like sift through those
and but yeah so far um it's been quite
effective in terms of our approach to it
in terms of the number of repeat reports
that we receive
and so we just continue with that so the
enforcement group meets
every monday and obviously review what's
coming the week before
and we get a report every monday morning
and go through all of the
addresses and pick up any kind of like
businesses or open spaces
and we work quite closely with our main
housing provider
and also with youth services and
obviously greater manchester police
and so that's kind of where we're up to
on a weekly
basis i don't know whether anyone's got
any questions
about that or about the report that's
been submitted
uh thanks helen before i invite
questions i did find the uh
the little chart on reported covid
breaches to be very revealing
um that the south of the borough has
more more uh breaches reported than
anywhere else
that's quite revealing in itself um
the other thing that has been raised
with me this week and
um i will i won't focus on on the
individuals but i've had a few inquiries
about
ice cream vet cell vendors coffee
vendors
in parks in in um canal banks etc
and and how they are a magnet for
attracting large groups of people to
swarm around them
um particularly uh i know there's a
couple of friends groups of parks who
are very upset
that somebody uh that a new coffee uh
mobile coffee van has been given keys to
david hume park
clearly we are licensing these people to
do that but um
i know nigel's on the call with us no if
i send you the details across
can you have a look at it and uh without
going into the details at this meeting
yes of course if you throw that on to me
and i'll fold that onto the the right
team in regulatory services to follow
that top
yeah thank you i've got eleanor wants to
come in
yeah just to say um it i think
that if we have difficulties with the
gap between guidance and regulations
um but i would say to anybody who's
watching this um
if there is a crowd of people around
outdoors is always safer but it re you
don't want to be in a crowd at all at
the moment
so i would um think very very carefully
before you join any queue for any coffee
or
ice cream or anything at this time we'd
be much better taking your own coffee
with you
at this point rather than being in any
risk of being in a crowded situation
you know really even outdoors do do
please take care
um just to add to what ellen has just
said then as well i think the way
people interpret kind of legislation is
that they think because they can't then
they should and
you know i think people have got to kind
of assess that risk for themselves and
echo what you say around if there's a
and i've seen photographs of people kind
of queueing for coffee and congregating
outside or
this two households sharing a bench that
outside having coffee and croissant
you know assess the risk for yourself as
an individual and just because you might
be able to legally do something
doesn't necessarily mean that you should
thank you ellen are there any questions
yes eve please can you come in
yeah i just wondered as part of the
arena of this group will there
also be the element around zero
tolerance
towards provider staff um
in terms of anti-social behavior
will will that be picked up through this
stream the reason i ask is that there
are instances where
members of the public and patients do
um present
difficult situations for practices
where they might practice staff might
experience quite threatening behavior
and as the organization that represents
them i'm finding it difficult to know
how to access
help for that in particular whether it's
covid or
or for some other reason so if there's
somebody that i can specifically liaise
with i would be really grateful
um hi eve i'm helen so i manage the
community safety team so
i'll get my details over to you in my
phone number but yeah that's certainly
something that we can help with
thank you very much thank you helen are
there any further questions at all from
anybody
i don't see anybody so thank you helen
uh we're on to uh the uh uh engagement
board activity and feedback
um can i just start before i throw it up
to the floor of
welcoming the briefing for all
councillors eleanor that you're putting
on on the 1st of february at 6 o'clock
i won't be able to attend i'm already
committed to another meeting but
i do think that that will be very
helpful and and certainly in getting
some of the key messages that we want
our counselors to be
uh be spreading amongst the communities
that they represent
i said i don't want anything to add at
all to uh to this part of the meeting
no hands up i'll also add elena that i
think the messaging we have been putting
out has been effective
i certainly what i see on twitter on the
social media site
uh i always do retweet and i think it it
has
um generated a lot of interest amongst
amongst the
people who are on that particular site
i don't so much do facebook but i do
know people who do do facebook and
i've commented also positively about the
messaging that we're getting out there
so
thank you thank you for the efforts
there well i'll thank um
ellie in our comms team and the rest of
the comms team for that because they've
been doing a fantastic job ellie only
started with us at the beginning of
january and she's
absolutely um absolutely on top of it so
it's fantastic to have her in the team
that's great great and i would i would
say if ellie wants
at all to ever come and ask uh or find
out
if there are anything she can all she's
got to do is contact herself
and and i'll put her in touch with
whoever to assist her in in that role
thank you thank you is there any other
business at all
for this meeting today
there isn't any so we meet again in a
fortnight's time at the same time
uh can i thank you all for your
attendance today and
can i just place on record again my
thanks to at the staff at trafford
uh the ccg and everybody that's involved
in fighting this pandemic and our
volunteers as well
and and let's keep keep keep keep at it
because
we will get there thank you very much
for your attendance today
thank you everybody thank you bye bye